Do you have to know when to say goodbye
to pieces that you love but just don't
make economic sense?
Um,
it's the toughest thing for me to do
because I like,
I think I fantasize myself as some sort
of,
you know,
curator on a deadline every,
every,
every season.
Um,
there are always the two to $3,000
experiments that do not make economic
sense in which I get wrapped on the
knuckles.
You know,
you know,
by,
fellow executives at Southerby's,
you without a doubt the trend,
you know,
in the better 20th century design
options is to focus on the higher and
higher value.
It's what makes economic sense.
And,
um,
without a doubt I spend much more of my
time focusing on the few pieces that are
worth in the six figures then I can with
collections of objects that are worth a
few thousand dollars a piece.
So the most difficult thing is to say
goodbye to a piece that you know,
that if you really treated it with,
with a kind of reverence,
you could,
you know,
introduced to a new group of collectors,
but that it's just not ready yet for
primetime.
And then,
and then you hate it.
If that piece ends up at a,
at a smaller auction house,
and you know,
maybe it doesn't get photographed very
well,
or maybe it ends up on Ebay and you
know,
but you have to,
you have to know when.